[Music]
this
chick who was an ex-mma fighter named
gina carano
uh was fired from her role on the
mandalorian yeah okay
al watches the show yeah um he said that
uh
she's useless on the show yeah her her
character is important
but she's a horrible actress yeah she's
basically
i think basically what happened was she
was a legit mma fighter so like she
started getting these action
roles and i think it's just like oh this
adds validity
to this person in the movie because she
can really do these things in real life
right
right so i get that and sure she's in
the show is she kicking people's ass in
the show
yeah right yeah and she can literally
kick ass right
in real life because she used to be an
mma fighter i get i get what hollywood
does right
um so she tweets out something i think
it was tweet or she basically put out
this and she goes uh
she was talking she basically compared
the persecution of republicans
um and trumpers to the nazi persecution
of jews
okay she goes jews were beaten in the
streets not by nazi soldiers
but by their neighbors even by children
because history is edited most people
today don't realize
that to get to that point where nazi
soldiers could easily round up thousands
of jews
the government first made their own
neighbors hate them simply for being
jews
how is that any different from hating
someone for their political views
now she got fired for saying this
um first of all shouts to jews bro
the jews they [ __ ] got it locked bro
they really do they got it
locked where's dove you know we need his
opinion on it right now he's getting
feasted on by the roanoke
yeah yo all that um like the jewish
chinese relationship
uh that really it does like reign true
like you know how like
that's where jews go on christmas oh
yeah yeah
chinese food places yeah yeah yeah and
now the chinese are eating the juice
in florida but uh so
um i'm actually curious what dove has to
say it's a bummer he's not here but
uh it is interesting right because what
she's trying to say now listen anytime
you liken anything to the holocaust
you could definitely make the argument
that you are dismissing the severity of
the holocaust
right the same is immediately going to
happen exactly and the same thing with
slavery right it's like any time you
call like when athletes call themselves
oh this is modern-day slavery it's like
you're kind of belittling how horrible
slavery was and like
we say that um now you could make
arguments for both right you could say
like
when athletes talk about being slaves
they're talking about their freedom to
operate in the world is restricted
based on these contracts right and that
is absolutely nothing like slavery and i
understand why there's pushback
especially from the black community you
hear it from like the conservative side
who is just trying to do anything they
can to like shut athletes up
but you also hear from the black
community that's like hey can we not
liken everything to slavery
we're belittling how horrendous slavery
was right
most slaves would in a heartbeat switch
places with a professional athlete
absolutely
yeah um so
the thing with what she's saying here is
interesting
because she's not saying i think this is
more nuanced she's not saying that
what republicans go through is the same
as
what jews went through in nazi germany
right what she's saying is
this is the groundwork for what happened
to jews yes in other words you first
need to make it
okay to publicly hate someone and shame
them
and then you could do whatever you want
with those people
so do i think in america in the year
that there's ever gonna be a time where
we're just rounding up trump supporters
half the country like you know how big
the [ __ ] camps are gonna need to be
like we didn't even have enough room for
the native americans there's no way
we're going to have enough room to put
74.
barely a minority barely a minority
barely
barely 49 49.5
like so that can't happen like jews were
a super super small minority in
germany so this is completely
unrealistic but what she's saying is you
can't
allow hatred
towards a group of people because when
you openly hate a group of people
all of a sudden it becomes very easy to
inflict acts of violence
you can't make a person radioactive for
who they are that's kind of what you're
saying like yeah you're gonna hate this
person automatically because she's a
trumper
and when when they are when it's open to
hate them yeah
violence is very easy like remember a
punch a trump supporter or something or
punch a mega
person yeah back in the day like it was
just like a
a a saying so it's like yeah they we
maga people are racist and the sexist
and all these other things so you might
as well just punch them in the face
and a punch of nazi that was it but they
were referring to the mag of people
essentially and um it is kind of weird
that
nobody ever has issue the other way
around that's what i was gonna say
we've been comparing trump to hitler for
four years
now the comparisons are stronger than
ever nobody ever
says hey that's triggering do you
understand that hitler killed six that's
too true like we can label that is
really interesting that's what bothers
me about this i think what she's saying
is stupid
like i understand the general point that
she's trying to make and that's not
stupid she takes it to a stupid place
but people compare trump to hitler on
the other side for four years
and nobody's losing jobs yeah there
seems to be no issue with that
whatsoever
so the left is completely okay when
people
use hitler as something
i don't know like a a way to like judge
how horrible human being is yes and
apply that
on conservatives right trump is hitler
right ted cruz is hitler proud boys and
all these days are
nazis etc they're applying the nazi
germany
um likeness all the time how is that not
marginalizing the death of six million
jews
it completely marginalizes i just don't
understand how the other side doesn't
apply
just to be fair i do think both sides do
it like
whenever there's like some type of uh
yes and that's
annoying they always go to him i don't
think this is fireball but that that is
uh i was actually talking to mark about
this
uh the other day before he had corona
and uh
and uh he brought up things like who did
people compare people to
before hitler because hitler is the
litmus test for horrible
yeah right so and i guess it was
apparently napoleon
really yeah like i guess the napoleonic
times were like incredibly brutal
war and people just getting [ __ ]
massacred all the time so he was this
person who was trying to dominate the
whole world and looked at as incredibly
evil
hitler came around and now napoleon's
like oh remember that cute guy was a
good general
yeah like how crazy is that do you think
there'll be somebody worse that comes
along and then
hitler becomes napoleon i mean hopefully
not but it's possible
isn't that [ __ ] crazy all it takes is
one person to do a little bit worse
thing than you
and all of a sudden you're off scot-free
remember george bush most hated man in
america
now a sudden best friends with michelle
obama passing around [ __ ]
lozenges and [ __ ] during every single uh
inauguration yep
people love their relationship yep
that's amazing so
trump is one bad guy away from being
remember that funny guy they used to
tweet the crazy [ __ ]
yeah that's a good point and maybe all
these politicians know that
you're just the latest person on the
whipping post or whatever yeah yeah
anyway so back to this i don't think
that this is that absurd
i i don't i don't think it's absurd if
the point she's trying to make is hey we
can't tolerate this behavior
where you allow people to just openly
hate someone else
i agree with that right when you what
else is she going to liken it to
if you want to show severity you use an
example more extreme than the one that
you're in
i think it's just so much more extreme
that it's ridiculous but i still stand
by
oh but i thought her thing is this isn't
what it is this is where it goes
this is the beginning of it yeah and i i
said the same thing when people compared
trump
to hitler in his first year in office i
was like this is way too [ __ ] early
to do let him cook a little yeah
let him get there he's just warming up
marinade let's just marinate this trump
this trump
trump and hatred or whatever let that
marinate when a couple trumps get
[ __ ] knocked out then
we got something right now assuming but
again i don't think this is fireable
this is not something you get fired for
and if it is start looking at the
[ __ ] who compare trump to
hitler for four years
yeah why does it now how does that
undermine how does that not undermine
what the jews went through let's try to
break that down why do you think that is
why where's the concentration camps
where do those happen in the past four
years
none what do you think i'm saying the
u.s where did trump put people in
concentration camps
tell me the steps that are so
holocaust-like why is it that you can
like it this is what's the difference
you can liken someone to the persecutor
you can't liken someone to the
persecuted
so it's almost like it's
i guess it's no different than i imagine
how black people feel about slavery
right we can call anybody a slave master
but once you start calling yourself yeah
it's like i'm basically a slave
like if some white person was like yeah
look at the treatment that i'm getting
okay it's like i'm basically a slave
black people like yo
y'all don't even know what it's like
yeah to be a slave
but if you said yeah the way this guy
runs a company he's like a slave master
the way elon
musk runs a company he's a slave master
i don't know if black people are going
hey you're belittling
how horrible slave masters are yeah i
don't think they would get as much
pushback
if any but that's interesting but it's
an implied thing if trump is
hitler aren't the rest of the nation the
persecuted aren't they saying we are the
persecuted yes
i guess they're not explicitly saying it
so there's like um what a
plausible deniability yes but it's
essentially the same implication is the
same thing yeah but that is the way that
you protect yourself
you just don't you don't take on the
struggle
yeah right you just pass on the
persecution right
and that is completely scot-free and i
think
sorry to interrupt but we do this all
the time where we're like uh uh he's
he's a nazi about grammar yeah right
yeah
yeah yeah yeah grammar nazis exactly
grammar nazi right he's a soup nazi like
we use the word nazi interchangeably
with someone who's a real pain in the
ass
like nazi shouldn't equal pain in the
ass that's true but we've
kind of mean kind of meat yeah yeah
doesn't give you soup
he's always telling me where to put
commas right this guy
and that's what that's the comedic
juxtaposition right let's describe
something with something way more severe
right when you call say someone looks
like a whale or someone looks like a
manatee
yeah right they don't actually look like
a manatee but you're describing them in
a way more severe way and that's why
it's funny right
right obviously she's not trying to be
funny right here but she's using the
same tactic
yeah of describing her situation in a
way more severe way so people pay
attention to it
have they been trying to get rid of her
for a while like is this enough
yeah that might be i think i think so
disney also super woke though
my girl was watching now if there's
anyone oh
yeah i understand yeah well
there is any company oh yeah if there is
any company on this planet yeah that
should not
cancel her that's true for these beliefs
maybe they're trying to make it right
you know
it's a company started by good old walt
disney
oh maybe you're right maybe they're
super sensitive to their past
yeah walt disney was a nazi sympathizer
back in the day or allegedly i don't
know exactly what he said but i think
it's pretty common knowledge that he was
that's where you hear a lot
right now what i was going to say is my
girl first of all disney i've always
noticed has been kind of progressive in
certain ways like they had that one
cinderella where brandy was cinderella
right and like he's a black girl that
was one of the stepsisters and two white
girls
but she put on aladdin after that and
then there was like a disclaimer that
was like
we understand that some of this stuff
was offensive rather than deleting and
then like editing out history
we think it's important to have these
conversations but like any movie they
have
we started going through we stopped the
movie we're like what about this movie
could this be offensive
and any movie that could be offensive
they have that disclaimer that's just
their way of going
it costs too much to change this [ __ ] so
keep watching this [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know you like it but
they are great they're on that like
we're very much on the forefront of like
the woke movement or whatever yeah
so this is i guess in line with that but
i don't think this is fireball i just
don't
yeah you can call it stupid i do i don't
think it's fire but we also
use hyperbole every single day yeah
career like that's what we literally do
like what she's doing she's not doing it
for comedic purposes she's doing it for
dramatic purposes but like
for a living what we do is exaggerate
things so it's funny
so when we see someone else exaggerate
things we're like oh yeah that's
that's relatable that's what we do maybe
that's why it's not so shocking
but for these literalists right these
like suits these corporate [ __ ]
who don't know how to think outside
of like right in front of their face
maybe they're just like uh oh people
could
cancel their subscriptions if she's
maybe this is a stupid counter argument
but we even the way we all use language
like when people say literally it
doesn't mean literally anymore
gary goldman has a great bit about it
how like now it it's become
it even just means figuratively oh he's
literally a thousand pounds yeah
we all do that everybody exaggerates
language yes we all have a boss that's a
slave driver slave master nobody's like
a stand-up so they get it in the office
we all say it so i don't
and you know what's interesting she
actually knows
a little bit about yeah i didn't know
that [ __ ] neither did i
i thought it was like hitler turned on
the light and then that's it
with the jews i didn't but it makes way
more sense that they slowly need to gain
support
yeah they slowly need to gain support
for this behavior
yeah and they tolerate these actions
from like
the regular germans or in the street not
i mean this is
i don't know it's kind of weird if if
you're jewish i'm really
i'm really curious if you're jewish
do you not agree with this on some level
i think ben shapiro supported her
actually
and he's you know head
media jew but like which is very much
had you
if your head meeting you you had jewish
boy
but i i wonder if like as a jew as a jew
in this situation you're like hey listen
we've studied this
we know how this works she's not wrong
do we think this will happen in america
no we don't think this will happen in
america uh
they don't think this will happen in
america to non-jews but if you ask the
average jew if they think that jewish
persecution could happen again
they believe that it could yeah my
jewish friends i asked them
and they're like absolutely a hundred
percent it could happen and it happened
quicker than you ever believed
so i bet if i i believe a race war could
start
oh you don't think we're back to norms
no
really i still think we're on edge son
we got this chappelle show back bro
we got the first two seasons all of a
sudden that storm the capital they
didn't
disappear because there was no chappelle
show now that
now that the chappelle show is back and
they can watch sketch comments we need a
hero we got
everything's fine we got a hero though
we have that's one of those he's not the
hero that we asked for but he's the one
we deserve what is the best
[ __ ] yeah the one we deserve i think
it's the one we deserve too
but that's the thing man so jews still
feel that they could be prosecuted and
black people still feel that there could
be a civil war
that's interesting yeah and i can't tell
you not to feel that
because the way that you look at history
it seems incredibly easy yeah
right the way that akash and i look at
history we're like
i ain't gonna have it but it's not we
didn't grow up learning about this [ __ ]
non-stop going hey it could happen yeah
so
yeah this is this is a really tricky one
if she wasn't such a trash actress go
yeah that's what i was just about to say
and this one i really just think
it's almost like when um a company drops
an athlete for some little thing they
say but it's like yeah you know like the
athlete was just like starting to play
trash and so it's like ah any reason i
could let him go i think that's what
they were just looking for something
boom you gave us a nice out where we
don't look bad for firing some woman
but i also think if she was on the other
side there wouldn't be this firestorm if
she was on the liberal side
and again it might be different because
the history of being persecuted but
a lot of people pointed out the things
that uh
like the the anti-minority movement or i
guess was whatever in the last four
years and like they were like yo this is
how the holocaust started
this is how x started that's how y
started this is how this like that's
that's been happening on the other side
this is just the first time we heard a
trump supporter saying it about
themselves
and now it's a and now it's a problem
and again it might be different because
minorities particularly black people had
such a history of being persecuted in
america that you look at them you're
like yeah now that's more plausible than
a white female trumper yeah i was
actually i was actually watching this
documentary
and they said like during the trump
years like white
extremism went up 55 like
throughout those four years wow that's a
little scary
yeah wow i get it but you know biden won
yeah so hopefully it goes down but the
fact that it's like you just don't think
you can have that
drastic of an increase maybe that's
because it came from nothing
like if there was two
acts of white terrorism or whatever it
is or white extremism
in the year 2016
and then there was three in 2017 that's
up 50
but that doesn't mean it's tons more
i do believe it went up a good amount
and i think you could feel it and we're
all on edge but i also think
this kind of [ __ ] only makes it worse
you're making that [ __ ] up entirely bro
come on stop it stop trying to steal my
country
i'm trying to stay in my country bro i
wanna stole the vote bruh
say what you already stole the vote stop
it i knew you were part of that show you
all probably made the machine yeah you
know what it sounds like you need was
that a hero
i wish we knew one dog i wish we knew a
hero i need a hero dude
oh my god bro yo what if batman
after saving gotham came out he's like i
am your hero
new yorkers like [ __ ] out of here bro
you went in spandex bro what the [ __ ]
you win
what if instead of doing it bailed you
out what if instead of that it was bruce
wayne saying it after a ruthless
corporate takeover of wayne
what if that's when he's here a moment
what if that's when he was like hey
wayne enterprises stock up 50 percent
i am a hero i'm the hero
non-stockholders too i'm your hero
i have courage you don't agree it's
cause you're cowards
[Laughter]
hey does anybody disagree with me you
must be a coward
cause holy cowards disagree with a hero
where's patrice we need jupiter trees